hey
what are you thinking about on on a
world title fight
the cage closes are you just zoned in on
like
different moves and techniques or are
you just kind of just waiting for the
bell to go like
what's going through your head before
they go ding ding ding and
do the nerves stop at the fir first
punch
or do they kind of just what's that i
mean i i just can't imagine being in the
cage
i i if you wanna i'm gonna i'm gonna
give you a little tour of how i lived
through the week
leading up before a fight awesome
because it started start for me
it start much earlier than that it
started when i signed the contract
even before i signed a contract because
i'm thinking
ah you know i'm watching one fight now
i'm like maybe i'm gonna fight this guy
or this guy
normally you when you're a champion you
know who you're gonna fight next
you know the possibilities you know that
you're gonna fight the winner of that
fight
so you're gonna pay attention to the
fight that gonna declare
the number one contender so your
butterfly is already started
and as you watch the fight you start
making scenario is this guy
i'm gonna do this if this guy i'm gonna
do this so you see your brain already
start
for me because i'm obsessive compulsive
that's how it works then when you know
who you're fighting
now you know you're going up against you
right away start making
out scenarios in your head as much as
you think about sex and your lie
in your head i was thinking as i was
thinking about sex as well but i was
thinking about
fighting like like just as much
and the closer you get to the fight
the cl the more you think about it and
it became it become like a
like a like a mental disease an
obsession
because you sometimes when you you have
some visions
and sometimes you see yourself winning
and sometimes you don't
you see yourself in trouble but the
thing is when you see yourself in
trouble
for me one of the trick i have to stay
positive and all that and control my
stress level is when i see myself losing
i i
don't let go on that negative
thought i force myself to think of how
i'm gonna
take back the upper hand of that
situation
and turn it to my advantage and then i'm
gonna then i can let go my thought and
do something else in my
and these thoughts before i fight and
i'm talking about like
like two months sometime two months even
a month two two months all the way to
the fight will
hunt you it hunt me
like crazy every second every minute of
my
existence when i'm driving my car when i
eating
before i go to bed and it's get worse as
the fight goes on it gets worse and it
it it weighs very heavy on my shoulder
and it's crazy it drives me nuts
especially the week of the fight
because you get into press conference
and when you promote a fight you get to
see your opponent
and you the the the print that he left
in your brain
and the scar that he left because he's
talking to you stuff that he's saying
get really to you an emotional level so
you're trying to start making imagery
not only about the fight but what you're
gonna
say to him and if you say that how
you're gonna answer back and everything
so everything
it's like a fight and it's get worse and
and the week of the
fight you have to lose weight and when
you lose weight
it's not a pleasant experience and
when i'm cutting weight it's very hard
sometimes you want to give up you want
to get out of the sauna
but you always i'm thinking that my
opponent is right next to me
and i'm not allowed to show any weakness
so until i
have made ways i don't show any weakness
then i make weight i
do i go to the weigh-in and
i'm gonna tell you the truth the night
before the fight i never sleep well
never and never never see why because
there's too much scenario in my mind
that is hunted it's hunting my mind i
cannot
sleep i'm turning in my bed then but if
you do this i'm gonna do
that and then i'm turning and then
sometimes i see myself winning sometimes
i don't and i have to force myself to
finish on top it
it's an obsession and it drives me nuts
so i sleep very very little
the the the few nights before the fight
because i'm going nuts
so the day of the fight when i wake up i
always tell myself the same thing
i always feel like [ __ ] and i'm always
like man i
i don't feel good today i feel like [ __ ]
like man i don't know
probably because i don't sleep well the
night before and i thought at one point
when i was young that this would go away
and with the experience i will be able
to feel better uh with that
but it got it's getting worse every time
because every fight is bigger than the
last one
and with time you realize that it's
normal
and that stress that fear you cannot let
it consume you
because fear is like fire it can help
you cook your food but it can also burn
you
and i know that fear and stress will
help me
to increase my reaction time my my
decision making time so it's my friend
and i embrace it i want it
to i want to be afraid because i know if
i'm not afraid that's mira does not care
about what's gonna happen
and i might not be fighting at the best
of my abilities
so i'm going crazy the whole time i'm
going nuts
but as a team
it cannot be any weak link you know so i
have to showcase
confidence in front of my trainer so
when they ask me hey are you okay
i'm like yes man i'm ready to go i can't
wait man it's gonna be fun
can't wait even though the down inside
i'm lying because i'm scared as hell
and i'm very uncomfortable you know i'm
terrified
and because i'm thinking i'm like man
maybe i'm going to be humiliated or
something i'm going to get knocked out
you know
cold but these these that's this despair
makes me be better and perform at my
best
so all that day the day that i'm
fighting is the longest day of my life
it's crazy because so much stress going
on
until i go to the locker room and when
you go to the locker room for example in
my last fight
against michael bisping it was crazy
because
it was like my locker room was cursed
all my training partner was getting
knocked out
all the guys from my team were getting
knocked out they were all coming back in
the locker room all messed up all
of them all like with that ice bag on
the head
like knocked out like it was bad so i
was like freaking out i was thinking i
started thinking
myself like man maybe it's a bad day
maybe we're cursed or
even though i'm not super superstitious
i'm like man
maybe in in my gym what we do is not
right maybe we
we don't do the right thing and we you
know what i mean
we're all as ben you know maybe things
we're not as good as we think
maybe we need to change our mittens and
then the fight get close
then you see you watch a fight on tv and
you don't you never know
you try to predict at what time you're
gonna go on you know you're the last
fight so
you see some guys getting knocked out
and you're like okay now i need to
warm up because it's coming out soon and
as you warm up
it changed something in your mind
because when you start hitting the pads
it makes your confidence grow and this
the
the scare guy that i was before now
start to disappear
because i'm starting to get confidence
because
i remember the mechanic of my movement
the perfection of my punches
and my technique and everything and
making me remember how good i am and
oh yeah this i'm i can't do that well
you know like now i remember
how good i am how much i'm a i'm a beast
in the gym
you know i'm how much uh the sacrifice
i've done to be here
you know how much i i took care of
myself for that preparation how much
hardcore sparing i had i'm sure he
didn't have the hardcore spy ring that i
that i had to go to
i'm sure he didn't have the he didn't
make the sacrifice that i did
you know i'm sure he didn't fought those
beasts that i had to fight during my
training camp i
had to go to hell to my training camp
i'm sure he didn't go to the same hell
that i did
start makes you remember this and then
you became a different person
and then times fly and then and now
there's
someone in the ufc that come knock at
your door and say hey saint pierre
you're up next
so when that moment come have a little
ritual that i do
i go in the bathroom i look at myself in
the mirror i'm alone
and only my coach knows what i'm doing
and i'm looking myself in the mirror and
i try to
make my confidence go and i'm talking to
myself you know i'm not a
i'm not a cocky person in public but i'm
trying to be
in in private when i'm talking to myself
i'm i'm telling myself like
i'm stronger than him i'm better than
him i'm more well prepared
i'm way more athletic than he is you
know i went through
hell you know i'm a much much better
fighter
i'm gonna win this fight i'm gonna show
these young kids that lose their fight
tonight our thing should be done
and i'm gonna show them that i'm the i'm
the [ __ ] king in this gym
i'm gonna they're gonna i'm gonna give
the example and then and then i'm then
i'm
kicking out the door and i'm a different
person than when i came
so the jury said that you see now today
is not the same than the one that is
going to fight and
is about to step in the octagon and when
i kick the door
and i'm about to do my walk now it's on
cruise control i don't have time to
think because if i think
i miss the opportunity i miss and and i
can get clipped
so it's all about cruise control it's
like when you play golf
you hit the ball the ball is in the air
there's nothing you can do to change the
result of the fight to change the
outcome because all my work is done
now the only thing i can do is to do it
to to
to let myself go with the cruise control
to trust my instinct
that's how it goes [ __ ] yeah yeah
amazing
yeah i love it so is it kind of yours
people are like oh i come you don't like
to fight yeah i
i don't like to fight because the person
i am now
is different than the person that is
getting ready to step into the octagon
we're both different human beings so
you're you're
operating a lot off of instinct in the
oct in in the fight
so does are you ever like three seconds
later you're like oh wow i just i
just blocked a really cool like you
don't even realize what's what
you know what's happening as it's
happening you're kind of
you're on a delay like your brain is on
a delay almost
no this is after when you watch the tape
because what happened is in training
you do so many repetition and repetition
and repetition you you drill certain
techniques
a thousand times so it become like an
automatic
in your brain it's an action reaction
you know when
you you you you have a certain action
you give the reaction in order to give
you the upper end and the fight
and you drill that so many times that it
become automatic
so when you fight you're on cruise
control everything you do
it's a reflection of what you've been
working on
through the last past 10 years
of your life and i say 10 years maybe
you're the last past 30
30 years because i started when i was a
kid you know
so it there there's no uh accident
i believe that everything happened
because of a reason because you
your your reaction everything is a cause
and effect
you know and and that's how it goes wow
it was interesting when they interviewed
i i saw gachi walking back to his locker
room after the ferguson fight and they
were like man it's crazy like you threw
some
leg kicks in there he's like i [ __ ]
threw some leg kicks in there
like like holy [ __ ] like he didn't even
remember i mean it's yeah yeah
you're on cruise control for me i
remember in one of my fights
i came back it's a five-round fight when
you fight for a championship it's
it's five rounds i was fighting johnny
and drix
after my third round i got rocked in my
third round
after that sorry after the second round
i got rocked in the second round
so i go back in the stool
and my my corner men are like hey george
this is the final round it's 2-2
the this is the fifth round is the one
that gonna win this round gonna win the
fight so it's a this is a decisive round
you have to give
everything you got you know if you want
to stay champion you have to give it all
and i look at the guy i'm like guys
you're making a mistake it's the third
round
and they're like no george is the fifth
round and i look at the
the screen i'm like [ __ ] yeah it's the
it's the fifth round because i got rock
i lost time
oh my god so i was on cruise control
that all time so that's what i'm that's
why i mean
it's a normal thing we're on survival
mode
you can't say i play baseball i play
soccer play basketball but you don't
play fighting
and this is something that we all have
inside of our of ourselves i can put
anybody in in a situation that he's
gonna have to fight
either to protect himself or to protect
someone that he loves
i can put everybody i don't care the
nicest person
i can put in a situation like my mother
who's the nicest person i know
i can put her in a situation that she
would be forced to fight in order to
protect her kids
she will she cannot do it well of course
she's not a fighter but she will
so fighting we can all relate to it
because it's something that we all have
to do
at least once in our life you know like
it's something that we can relate it's
in in our
most basic instinct that's why it's not
like playing basketball it's it's
fighting it's different
and the proof of that if you don't
believe me look at
what happened if you go watch a
basketball game or a baseball game
and a fight breaks out in the stair in
the in the crowd
you will stop watching the game and look
at the fight because the fight is
threatening
it's it's threatened threatening you it
it
it has something different a different
appeals
to what is going on as a game maybe you
don't like that
that sort of of uh entertainment you
know
and it's not an entertainment that is
made to everybody but everybody can
relate to fighting
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude